dans le débat sur france 24 consacrait à
la tunisie alors que le compte à rebours
a commencé avant le référendum
constitutionnel du 25 juillet après le
gel du parlement kaïssa aide avait
décidé par décret d'organiser ce
référendum pour valider une nouvelle
constitution puis des élections
législatives le 17 décembre seulement
voilà un rapport de la commission de
venise organe consultatif du conseil de
l'europe souligner l'incongruité de
l'annonce d'un tel référendum avant la
publication du projet de la nouvelle
constitution le président tunisien a
sommé les membres de cette commission de
quitter immédiatement la tunisie pour
ingérence dans les affaires internes ce
rapport rejoint pourtant les critiques
des différents partis tunisiens exclus
du dialogue national park high sayed lui
gtt la puissante centrale syndicale
appelle à une grève nationale du secteur
public le 16 juin dans ce contexte le
maintien du sommet de la francophonie en
tunisie est de plus en plus incertain
l'algérie a appelé un retour à la
démocratie
les bailleurs de fonds comme le fmi ont
émis des exigences de réformes alors
comment la tunisie se prépare-t-elle à
ce référendum constitutionnel quels sont
les objectifs de cailly ça aide le
président tunisien est il de plus en
plus isolé à l'intérieur et sur la scène
internationale
finalement quel avenir pour la tunisie
de caïx ça aide on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés hakim el karoui bonsoir bonsoir
chercheur à l'institut montaigne
essayiste franco kunis tunisien pardon
auteurs de rapports de plusieurs
rapports sur le maghreb et en
l'occurrence la stabilité du maghreb un
impératif pour l'europe et puis
également nouveau monde arabe nouvelle
politique arabe pour la france bienvenue
à vous en face de vous abdel majid azimi
bonsoir si vous êtes membre du comité
central du parti courant populaire
c'est-à-dire un parti après ça aide
bienvenue à vous également majid bouden
est avec nous bonsoir avocat franco
tunisien président de l'association des
avocats en droit international à paris
nous avons avec nous en duplex de tunis
jaguar bin mubarak bonsoir vous êtes
membre du comité exécutif du front de
salut national
constitutionnaliste on peut dire que
votre comité s'oppose lui a justement
kaïs saïd bienvenus à vous également
avant de démarrer ce débat hakim el
karoui j'aimerais qu'on redonne un peu
de contexte à ce qu'est la tunisie
aujourd'hui qu'inside a été élu pour son
profil on peut dire à politique
anti-corruption et depuis son arrivée au
pouvoir il a gelé les pouvoirs du
parlement il a décidé par décret
d'organiser un référendum
constitutionnel le 25 juillet puis des
élections législatives le 17 décembre la
seule question qui sera posée lors de ce
référendum sera êtes vous d'accord avec
la nouvelle constitution comment
expliquer hakim el karoui que le
président sayed et pu gouverner par
décrets quel est son objectif
à son objectif c'est de passer à une la
tunisie 3.0 au sens où il s'agit de
changer les dix ans d'acquis depuis 2011
toute la transformation politique il
considère et beaucoup de tunisiens avec
lui ça c'est vrai considère que ça a été
un échec et cet échec pour lui c'est
d'abord un échec institutionnels et donc
il veut changer les institutions et pour
ça il a fait la manière forte il a fait
ce qu'on n'a pas osé appeler un coup
d'état le 25 juillet et ensuite il a
gelé puis dissous toutes les
institutions politiques et une papesse à
un coup de force
techniquement c'est un coup d'état on
n'a pas appelé coup d'état pour éviter
ce coup d'état dans le langage
international et avec les accords qui as
a posé problème pour la coopération mais
de fait c'était un coup d'état
présidentielle c'est assez original et
tunisiens avaient inventé le coup d'état
du premier ministre en 87 là on a eu le
coup d'état du président depuis toutes
les institutions étaient gelés et il
refait tout seul un système
institutionnel et c'est là où le gros
problème c'est que comment est ce qu'on
peut voter sur un texte dont personne ne
connaît les fondements quand ya pas eu
de débat sur un sujet aussi important
les institutions d'un pays c'est ça ce
que dit la commission de venise très
sincèrement je pense qu'elle a raison
magie de boudin justement cette
commission de venise a publié un rapport
c'est un organe consultatif du conseil
de l'europe et elle dénonce à ce que
viennent dire effectivement hakim el
karoui le fait que l'on difficile de
faire un référendum soit une
constitution alors que le texte n aime
pas encore n'est pas encore écrit
kaïs est d'assommer donc ses membres de
quitter le pays en évoquant lingère
est-ce qu'elle a raison d'abord quand
elle dit que c'est un pont rue cette
commission ce qui se passe la commission
elle est consultatif dans quel doigt
d'un point de vue on l accepte qu'on
n'accepte pas il faut le discuter le
fait de répondre et de et de rejeter
même la discussion avec la avec cette
commission alors que la tunisie était et
elle participe à ces travaux est une
faute de la loire du président non bien
sûr et de la part de l'état tunisien
puisque le président et parle au nom de
l'état tunisien
là il faut pas personnaliser uniquement
la chose la tunisie a besoin de ces de
ces rapports internationaux elle elle a
besoin d'apaisement on est en train de
nous couper de tous nos partenaires le
fmi aujourd'hui pose la crédibilité de
la classe politique dans son ensemble
pourquoi parce que les ukrainiens juste
sur la commission on va écouter
justement le président queille cède sur
ce sujet
majeur je saisis l'occasion pour
rappeler qu'il n'est pas question de
s'immiscer dans nos affaires internes
comme le fait cette commission dite
commission de venise
aussi un membre de cette commission se
trouve en tunisie mk l'eau fut qu'il
s'en aille sur le champ à strassen brio
madrid
admet donc vous qu'il soutenait le
président pourquoi avoir viré on peut le
dire finalement les membres de la
commission de venise alors d'après ce
qu'on dit justement nos interlocuteurs
allait tout de même raison alors vu
juste corrigé interne on se tient le
président on se tient pas deux
présidents se tient le processus du 25
juillet qui aujourd'hui porté par le
président qui s'inquiète son été
quelqu'un d'autre nous l'aurions soutenu
soutenu aussi donc
c'est un processus populaire et non pas
un processus d'un an parce qu'on fait il
est venu le 25 juillet suite à des
manifestations et un ras-le-bol général
dans le pays et qu'elle sayyed a saisi
cet instant pour lancer le processus du
25 du fan's action colossaux de temps
mais évidemment tant qu'il est temps
qu'il dit vit pas
bien évidemment les raisons il a eu
raison de prendre alors il a eu raison
sur le fond sur la forme ça aurait été
le ministre des affaires étrangères sera
était un employé enfin quelqu'un de dudu
de la diplomatie tunisienne qui aurait
pris cette position peut-être que
derrière les termes au rite est
peut-être moins choquant pour les
occidentaux par contre nous considérons
que c'est de l'ingérence que fellah
convenable la commission de venise la
commission initie une commission
consultative pour l'europe si énormément
et collective oui même si on aurait
versé une commission qui a été crié
après la chute du mur de berlin pour
régler des problèmes juridiques dans
l'ex urss donc déjà on est dans une
position on est dans un schéma où cette
commission elle appartient à un conte
donc il n'est pas forcément enfin
qu'avec et le pardon elle appartient à
l'occident à l'europe ce n'est pas une
commission africaine c'est pas une
commission tunisienne donc quelque part
l'ingérence elles viennent du fait que
c'est une commission ont été les bougies
soit une ingérence européenne c'est ce
que vous dites on dit que c'est une
commune cette cette commission a
pratiqué de l'ingérence dans nos
affaires on sait que croit forcément
s'il comme signe aussi une assurance
européenne vous prenez pas le risque
justement de vous couper du conseil de
l'europe écoutez nous avons un processus
de 2,2 de correction de ce qui s'est
passé pendant dix ans et ben en fait ce
processus là il fallait un certain
nombre de personnes et faisant un
certain nombre d'entités des tas de
personnalités de partis politiques nous
prenons ça que tel qu'il est et nous
continuons à enfoncer g voire bin
mubarak votre réaction justement à ce
que vient de dire à des imaginales me
merci beaucoup je sais pas si j'ai bien
compris si j'ai bien entendu mais
apparemment il ya une problématique par
rapport à l'ingérence de la commission
de venise dans les affaires intérieures
de la tunisie ça le fait que je leur ai
demandé de quitter le pays
oui d'abord je dois rappeler que la
commission que la tunisie et membre de
la commission de venise il ya deux
tunisiens qui siège à la commission de
venise jeu si ce n'est la chabanne doyen
de la faculté des sciences juridiques
ainsi que ghazi ghrairi un juge qu'on le
juge administratif de renommée en
tunisie et qui siège à la commission et
que par acte internationale la tunisie a
adhéré à la commission de venise je
rappelle aussi que la présidente de la
commission de venise était dernièrement
en tunisie avant
avant la parution de ceux de cet avis
consultatif
elle a rencontré le président et side et
il n'a pas formulé d'objection par
rapport à ça et puis elle a rencontré
aussi des ministres du gouvernement de
gaza elle a rencontré aussi sadar
bellaïd qui est chargé de la commission
chargée de préparer le projet de
constitution est la rencontre est aussi
l'un des amis les plus proches de pc ça
aide à savoir
dernièrement ce n'est pas de la ministre
de l'emploi
oui là ce n'était pas de la gérance
dernièrement il ya quelques jours le
ministre de l'emploi tunisien a consulté
sur une affaire particulière conclut
elle la commission de venise
tout au long de ce processus la
commission de venise n'intervient pas le
seul dans les affaires intérieures de la
tunisie mais dès le moment que la
commission
adopte une position peut être réservé
par rapport au processus du coup d'état
de pyside en entier et particulièrement
concernant l' ordonnance modifiant la
composition de l'instance supérieure
indépendante pour les élections et
concernant aussi la conformité du
référendum en lui-même à la constitution
et aux standards internationaux
là ça devient vraiment de l'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures de la
tunisie et il s'agit d'un double
discours d'un discours classique d'un
d'un apprenti dictateur à qui aimait le
chaos rien juste une réaction alain
lanty dictateur vous allez réagir
également
moi je trouve le thématique de
l'ingérence elle est intéressante quand
on sait que la tunisie a été sauvé par
l'ingérence des pays étrangers l'an
dernier elles qui ont fourni
gratuitement des vaccins et que la
tunisie vit aujourd'hui grâce aux
financements internationaux
donc la tunisie est déjà dépendante la
tunisie est interconnecté
avec l'europe qui est juste sa proximité
avec l'algérie qui l'a beaucoup aidée
donc il faut qu'à vivre au risque de
s'isoler complètement de ce qu'ils sont
en train de la soutenir
l'aviron ça vient du fait que 1 si une
commission juridique d'après ce n'est
pas une commission les politiques et qui
met un avis politique sera un processus
politique notamment sur les élections
sur le timing sur la constitution 1 ça
c'est de l'ingérence la souveraineté
nationale la souveraineté nationale est
une ligne rouge et nous soutenons le
président pour ça à partir du moment où
donc j'entends
le camarade diawara qui disait il a été
reçu il n'ya pas longtemps je suis
désolé vladimir poutine quelques mois
avant la guerre il n'était pas persona
non grata et tout le monde lui parler et
tout le monde ne recevez
appartient évidemment c'est juste un
parallèle pour dire que pour dire est
que le terrorisme on reçoit par rapport
à des positions acquises it et
consultations et ont fait une
consultation juridique bien évidemment
si on est membre et d'ailleurs le
président il caille saïda je pense qu'il
a la tunisie va sortir de la commission
bien évidemment la de vue le ce qui se
passe c'est ce qui va se passer donc
elle va se couper de la commission de la
situation est très grave parce que c'est
pas parce qu'une commission ou une autre
partie aimé un avis qu'on coupe les
ponts quand chasse les gens qu'on
l'expulsé ça c'est le 19e siècle le
droit international dans en matière si
le retour de son international
n'a oublié le droit international
aujourd'hui il a évolué il a évolué
depuis nuremberg gh et ils évoluent de
façon constante il ne considère pas que
linger que la souveraineté permet tout
au 19e siècle à la souverainté
permettait tout c'est le discours
aujourd'hui des régimes autoritaires
comme la chine la russie et
la turquie où on veut dire par
souveraineté on fait ce qu'on veut
personne n'a droit de regard les droits
fondamentaux ça n'existe pas et c'est la
volonté du chef qui doit s'exprimer
c'est pas ça la souverainté aujourd'hui
selon les standards internationaux donc
on est en train de nous séparer de droit
des standards internationaux
on est en train de nous isoler et les
conséquences vont être très grave on va
avancer justement dans ce débat sur
l'organisation de ce référendum
constitutionnel abdel majid azimi un mot
justement comment le président peut-il
effectivement se dire qu'il va écrire un
texte de constitution ce dans les deux
mois qui viennent qui va être donc qui
doit être ensuite soumis à référendum le
25 juillet alors que j'ai vu que la
constitution de 2014 issu de la
révolution a mis 4 ans finalement à être
à sortir finalement texte et et vote
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'invitez pas
donc les parties à participer au
dialogue c'est notre position nous
aurons populaire nous pensons que le
dialogue doit être ouvert davantage
aux partis politiques la société civile
donc vous êtes différents degrés quand
je vous dis lui il quand je dis partis
politiques nous bien évidemment les
partis qui soutiennent le processus du
25 juillet on peut pas demander à des
gens qui s'opposent au processus du 25
juillet à des partis politiques de venir
se mettre autour de la table pour
discuter discuter de quoi est il rejette
en bloc le processus donc est ce qu'il
va se passer il y aura une nuit n'ont
pas été invités me semble-t-il à
participer au processus les partis n'ont
pas ainsi invités et nous trouvons que
c'est normal par contre semaines pour
voir normal dans une démocratie
parce que c'est le pulse et l'homme le
problème c'est que le processus du 25
juillet venu comme une réponse à l'échec
de ces parties là au pouvoir pendant dix
ans est venue une réponse une pré
révolte populaire qui a commencé le 25
juillet il est venue en réponse à des
problématiques économiques politiques et
de kleptocratie qui a gouverné pendant
dix ans à des mafieux des mafias où nous
avons au parlement tunisien nous avons
des des gens qui sont des contrebandiers
nous avons des gens qui ont des affaires
de terrorisme nous avons des gens qui
sont qui ont des affaires en justice en
la liste est longue donc scellé nombre
de caissettes
la rupture et le retour aux vraies
valeurs de la révolution j'avais envie
de mourir vous pouvez réagir justement à
ce que vient de dire à ce que viendrait
avec majid azimi votre parti lui il a
pas été invités à discuter de cette
constitution est ce que vous allez
boycotté le vote est ce que vous
dénoncez la méthode de kayes ces aides
oui nous on dénonce tout le processus
depuis le 25 juillet nom considérant
qu'il s'agit d'un coup des packs e
que nous boycottons d'une manière
globale y compris bien évidemment le
référendum prévu pour le 25 juillet
d'ailleurs référendum dans nos bouger et
jusque là inconnu on ne sait pas cela
il ya une ordonnance appelant les
électeurs à répondre à une question sur
un projet de constitution qui n'existe
pas la commission même qui est chargé de
rédiger ce projet de constitution n'est
pas encore constituée n'est pas encore
formé donc on sait pas de quoi il s'agit
exactement donc en boycottant le
processus tout en entier j'ai une petite
vous pensez que c'est la meilleure
qualification de la responsable de
boycotter
oui oui oui bien évidemment mais je
voudrais simplement revenir sur un petit
détail sur la question des partis
politiques qui sont responsables de
l'échec de la transition démocratique
qui serait probablement exclu de ce
dialogue
d'abord une grande partie de ses parts
de ces partis politiques ne revendique
pas une participation à un tel dialogue
de 2,2 il est vraiment bizarre de dire
ça parce que tout au long de ces dix
dernières années nous avons une
participation assez large de toutes les
formations politiques
le système de la transition était
tellement ouvert que tout le monde
pratiquement à participer à la
transition démocratique et assume une
partie de la responsabilité
si on veut faire le bilan finalement si
on veut exclure les partis qui ont
participé
soit aux différents parlements
successifs au gouvernement et à la à
l'accompagnement de la transition
démocratique il reste pas grand chose il
reste quelques parties microscopiques et
quelques partenaires de rixheim même lui
gtt luge et éthique et l'organisation la
centrale syndicale principal en tunisie
était un acteur fondamental de la
transition démocratique dans la
formation des gouvernements dans la
fixation des politiques publiques même
cet été mais j'étais ciolos et us border
moi je vous interromps avec gtt
d'ailleurs demande appellent à la grève
on va les écouter donc le gtt encore une
fois c'est elle on réunit en ce moment à
ma m est partie elle veut elle refuse de
participer à ce dialogue parce qu'elles
disent qu'il n'y a pas de visibilité de
la part de cana aide et ils appellent à
la grève le 16 juin on va les écouter
habana
nous avons averti à plusieurs reprises
que tout appel au dialogue doit être
fait de manière consultative d'achat il
ne peut pas être fait par directive ou
par décret aux maçons lors du dernier
appel à la consultation au dialogue
lancé par le président de la république
il n'y a pas eu de consultation et cela
va à l'encontre du décret numéro 30 qui
a été publié sans consultations
préalables alors qu'il aurait dû l'être
hakim el karoui ça veut dire que le
président se retrouve tout seul ce
qu'ils le souhaitaient mais la réponse
de luge et le gtt qui elles étaient
invités à discuter avec lui je crois que
si la même que celle des partis je crois
vraiment que c'est le but est que ça
vient de loin parce que lui considère
qu'il est des il est le dépositaire de
la volonté populaire contre tous les
partis toutes les organisations toutes
les institutions et ça va tellement loin
qu'il pense qu'il est le peuple
et il exerce maintenant ce pouvoir là
d'une façon très autoritaire très
verticale avec aussi des problèmes
juridiques et de libertés publiques ce
qui est nouveau tout donne un exemple
mati ben avraham burg ancien ministre
député il a été il y avait une affaire
le procureur de la république s'est
saisie de cette affaire il était
plaignants il est devenu il est devenu
responsable
il ya eu une enquête juge d'instruction
a conclu à un non-lieu le parquet s'est
opposé se trouve que il a un enfant il a
perdu sa femme petit enfant qui a six
ans il a fait la grève de la faim 30
jours 29 jours de grève de la faim sont
refusé de le libérer sans aucune aucune
justification ce qu'on voit maintenant
en tunisie sont que votre conclusion ce
à quoi on est petit dans une démocratie
alors c'était un des modèles des
démocraties et arabes à la tunisie à ça
la réalité le modèle il ya eu un travail
très long inefficace qui au bout de dix
ans était un échec et ça tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus il fallait
changer personne ne savait comment faire
d'une certaine manière alyssa reid à
libérer quelque chose le problème c'est
que au lieu de d'organiser une
transition tout de suite il a attendu et
petit à petit il a zappé tous les
contre-pouvoirs et maintenant ce qu'il
est en train de faire c'est qu'ils en
train d'imposer son pouvoir on le voit
avec ce cas-là de libertés publiques on
le voit avec le cade cette réforme
institutionnelle qu'il est en train de
décider tout seul et après ça va être
quoi ça va pas être un référendum sur la
constitution ça va être un kbis it pour
ou contre high side et ça ce n'est pas
du tout un modèle démocratique magique
bouder ce qu'il y ait encore des
contre-pouvoirs en tunisie aucun et le
problème c'est que
depuis un certain temps il y a des
choses vraiment fondamental il faut pas
rester dans le cercle de la constitution
il faut se poser des questions
fondamentales aujourd'hui dans quel état
est la tunisie l'état tunisie dans une
situation économique catastrophique la
tunisie dans la main ce qui est une
humiliation et on a rompu tous les
contacts avec le fmi qui est le même
mais le plus grand pourvoyeur de fonds
on en est en train de rompre les
relations avec l'union européenne on est
en train de nous isoler et il faut se
poser des questions simples en 1980 la
tunisie avait le même pib que la corée
du sud aujourd'hui la vente de saab ceux
de samsung pendant un week end produit
plus que la le pib tunisien bon donc de
l'autre côté faut se poser la question
que là la grande bretagne aujourd'hui le
royaume-uni n'a pas de constitution et
fonctionne donc aujourd'hui au lieu de
régler le problème sérieux fondamentale
on est en train de nous chamailler et ça
fait dix ans qu'on se chamaille sur des
choses qui deviennent secondaires par
rapport aux eaux à la vie réelle et
c'est là où on vient à la question de la
crédibilité
la question fondamentale c'est qu'il ya
eu le régime ben ali une révolution on à
pâturer tirer les leçons il y a eu
aucune aucune
personne avant du compte il ya eu les
dix ans des islamistes puisque c'est une
nouvelle honda canada et donc personne
n'a rendu compte qu'en essais de prends
ça c'est un fait réel mais au lieu de
deux au moins de demander des comptes à
ceux qui ont créé ça il ne brille ne
bouge pas et c'est ça son problème ce
qui n'a pas essayé de demander des
comptes à ceux qui ont créé cette
situation et il fait la même chose et on
va continuer comme ça est ce que c'est
bien le jeune âge mais est-ce qu'on est
quand même dans une dérive autoritaire
côté jeux rebondir sur les trois sujets
qui ont été dits on dit le problème
c'est pas la constitution si nous
pensons que le problème mimi la grosse
édition 2014 issu de la révolution
aujourd'hui la constitution 2014 qui est
issu de la révolution a
introduit ou à instaurer un système
politique que sa pratique a montré ses
limites et un blocage des institutions
et ça fait des années que nos
institutions sont bloqués ça fait des
années qu'on avait avant et de temps de
beji caïd sebsi on se souvient tous
qu'en belgique l'indicé psi disait avait
une direction et son premier ministre
tenait une autre direction changer la
constitution sinon il y aurait donc nous
en nous pensons que le système politique
alors c'est pas forcément l'oeil du
système politique et le système
électoral ça c'est des deux problèmes
majeurs que nous avons aujourd'hui qui
empêche de payer tournée qui empêchent
des réformes économiques qui ont
instauré une espèce de consensus
politique dont par les jaguars globale
est tout à l'heure et comptines et moi
attendaient monde amateur est ce que
vous savez exactement quelle
constitution qui essaie de mettre en
place
les lignes sont claires aujourd'hui
c'est un régime présidentiel sis
l'unification du pouvoir exécutif avec
un président de la république qui a
pouvoir y vivre avec un parlement qui
s'occupe de la 2de des lois tout
simplement et du contrôle et avec une
cour constitutionnelle il aura des
pouvoirs sans les parties devaient
circuler des parties pour que qu'il a
dit qu'il pleuvait pas de porter parce
que les partis n'ont personne n'a dit il
à jamais aujourd'hui il est pas de ce
que nous savons nous qui soutenons ce
processus et les pas question
aujourd'hui de dire on est soudé partie
où il y aura plus de parties demain donc
ça c'est pas l'ordre du jour n'étant pas
en état de déliquescence avec ce qui se
passe justement les par le décor 21 mai
la démocratie tunisienne et une
délégation en fait la démocratie depuis
vous parlez de données économiques les
zones économiques sais pas qui c'est qui
on est responsable aujourd'hui l'huile
et ça fait hériter disant tu à sion qui
date de dix ans je vous donne les yeux
de quelques chiffres
quelques chiffres en 2010 nous avons 15
milliards d'euros 15 milliards d'euros
de dettes 43 % du pib aujourd'hui nous
avons 82 milliards 2 82% du pib 32
milliards d'euros en 2010 il y avait
quatre cent quarante mille
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui nous avons eu
huit cent mille fonctionnaires nous
avons emprunté cette année début 2000
22,8 milliards 5 12 dinars non briec
pour payer les fonctionnaires cette
situation là c'est pas qu'elle
s'inquiète qu'il a crié il hérité de
cette situation là qu'aujourd'hui et des
réformes économiques et des réformes
sociales engagées et très vite parce que
les tunisiens mais ils sont en attente
de sa sage vous l'accord il a tout les
par contre sur le plan politique et sur
le plan politique il faut régler la
question politique tant qu'on n'a pas
réglé la question politique la
constitution du système politique du
monde de lectorat algérien on n'a rien
réglé
excusez moi du haut de vos biens
calendrier le 25 juillet et le 17
décembre 25 juillet référendum 17
décembre élections et après vous pouvez
dire et bien là qu'est ce qu'on fait des
réformes économiques des mesures
urgentes à prendre forcément ça il faut
qu'ils soient prises avant mais
évidemment parce que les gens ont des
difficultés économiques les gens ont des
difficultés pour se nourrir voilà mais
le processus politique est plus
important hakim répond pendant 10 ans on
a dit on peut pas faire de réformes à
cause des institutions parce que rien ne
passera au parlement depuis dix mois le
président a tous les pouvoirs peut faire
toutes les réformes qu'il veut il n'a
rien fait les discussions qui
s'éternisent avec le fmi c'est quoi ces
des discussions sur les réformes la
baisse de la masse salariale de la
fonction publique privatisation d'une ou
deux entreprises un peu moins de
compensation un peu plus de
libéralisation de l'économie rien de
tout cela n'a avancé le fmi dit nous on
a on a payé on a financé la tunisie
pendant dix ans maintenant c'est fini le
président a tous les pouvoirs rien n'a
été fait donc oui il ya urgence mais
pourquoi est ce qu'il ne fait rien et
pourquoi est ce qu'il s'obstine à
considérer que le seul sujet est
institutionnel et juridique certes il
est professeur de droit est pourquoi le
gouvernement n'est pas à la manoeuvre
c'est ça qui est très frappant
rien ne se passe que des discussions sur
les institutions et pendant ce temps là
il ya l'ukraine et à la famine qui
arrivent il ya l'inflation qui va qui
est extrêmement haute et il ya une
déstabiliser sur social qu'est qui va se
produire et alors la communauté à les
questions fondamentales c'est que le fmi
attend avec tous les pays du monde il
accepte la signature du ministre des
finances pour la tunisie ils ont vu que
chaque parti politique chaque classe
tous les régimes confondus ne respectez
pas sa parole et sa signature et ils ont
exigé que ce soit le miz des finances du
gouverneur de la banque centrale et pim
ils s'aiment et ils ont compris que ce
n'était pas ce n'était pas respecté ils
ont exigé la signature du premier
ministre maintenant ils ont en plus
élevé le niveau d'exigence ils veulent
la signature de luge et et et de
l'éthique a et c est donc mais on va où
les familles je suis d'accord avec vous
je vous invite à lire le livre de joseph
stiglitz prix n'ont pris nos vies de 2,2
d'économie américain quitté au fmi à la
banque mondiale qui a fait un livre de
300 pages qui explique que le fmi n'est
jamais intervenu dans un pays et qu'à
presse à termonde sans l'intervention le
pays reste
le fmi est minée par les pays à genoux
et les entraves de mecs c'est quoi il
conditionne et conditionne ces aides où
ces prêts à des réformes certaines sont
bonnes la réduction des du nombre de
fonctionnaires je pense que c'est une
bonne réforme parce que on a trop de
fonctionner en un nombre de
fonctionnaires que d'allemagne alors
qu'ils sont cette fois plus nombreux que
nous par contre le fmi et fait de
l'ingérence ils demandent de la
privatisation il ya des lobby derrière
le fmi demandé la levée des barrières
devenir chose qui selon vous quel side
en fait il n'est pas question de faire
appel au fmi en tout cas ces retours
entre pressions pour qu'il dirige pas
question de
savoir bin mubarak juste à moins
justement sur le fmi vous pouvez
répondre s'il vous plaît et ensuite on
va parler de la communauté
internationale pas seulement du fmi non
je voudrais d'abord un peu corrigé à un
chiffre sur le
le volume de la dette c'est pas 82% du
pib sa remontée depuis une année à
presque plus que 100 % 2
très fort c'est ça ta ce départ c'est
pas vrai s'ils sont licenciés a augmenté
et vous faites incinération que c'est
remonté et a essayé d'aller aux manettes
depuis ah non ce n'est pas vrai le seul
près qu'il a engagé depuis qu'est ce que
je puis le 25 juillet s'est attelée ces
milliards de francs qui veut dire que
non mais ça se termine et c'est beau
allez-y
jaguar une autre remarque sur sur la
dérive autoritaire du pouvoir de psa il
faut simplement rappeler que et saïda
commencé dès le 25 juillet par la
dissolution de l'instance provisoire de
contrôle de constitutionnalité des lois
c'était l'une de ses premières mesures
la dissolution par la suite du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et sa
reconstitution à sa manière puis
sa décision d'immuniser totalement ses
ordonnances et c'est décret loi contre
toute attaque et contrôle judiciaire il
faut aussi rappeler que l'époque de pc
saïd c'est le retour des séquelles de la
séquestration des individus c'est la
limitation de la liberté de circulation
c'est la violence policière dans le 14
janvier dernier on a vu un exemple d'une
d'un retour de la violence policière
c'est les procès politique c'est le
recours aux tribunaux militaires pour
juger des civils est jugé qu' des
députés c'est le transfert de 120
députés devant devant la justice pour la
tenue d'une séance plénière de
l'assemblée nationale c'est ça le régime
de kyle hyde c'est un c c'est un retour
à un régime autoritaire et très très
populiste et dangereux
j'ai l'intention oui oui sur le fmi
rapidement
oui
sur le fmi vous lui faisiez dire quelque
chose sur les familles
non sur le sur le fmi il faut d'abord il
faut d'abord relever la question
politique avant les questions techniques
sur dans les discussions du fmi avec le
gouvernement il ya un fond politique
c'est-à-dire ya un fond de crise
politique parce que le gouvernement de
madame boutin n'est pas un gouvernement
légal c'est pas un gouvernement qui a
passé par les canaux constitutionnel et
n'a pas été autorisé par le parlement et
n'a pas obtenu un vote de confiance dans
kate tous les engagements internationaux
de ce gouvernement sont douteux et c'est
pour cela aussi pas pour des raisons
techniques bien évidemment pour des
raison d'exigences financières et de
réformes que les faits me bloque le
financement du déficit budgétaire mais
aussi parce qu'il y a un problème
politique un problème d'instabilité pop
up politique et un problème aussi de
visibilité
nir de la tunisie avec high side et est
incertain donc que les bailleurs de
fonds trou beaucoup de difficultés
techniques et politiques pour s'engager
dans des discussions crédible avec le
gouvernement du québec à rebondir
justement sur ce qu'il vient de dire la
communauté internationale commence a
réagi à s'interroger effectivement sur
ces dérives autoritaires est ce que il
est question par exemple que la
francophonie que le sommet de la
francophonie dont qui devait avoir lieu
à djerba en tunisie ne soit pas n'ait
pas lieu donc en tunisie parce que
manifestement le canada s'y opposerait
les etats-unis qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs en tout cas les etats-unis
eux comptent réduire de moitié leur aide
à la tunisie au titre du budget donc de
l'année 2023 là ils disent les états
unis que c'est un moyen de rétorsion
économique qui sonne vraiment comme un
avertissement s qu'effectivement la
tunisie aujourd'hui est en train de
s'isoler et est ce que le sommet de la
francophonie va finir par ne pas avoir
lieu même en tunisie ça je sais pas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya deux types de
réactions suivant en fait la proximité
les américains les canadiens et
notamment le l'équipe by john key buy
donald a fait campagne sur leur route ou
le retour de la démocratie le soutien
démocratie après trump il voit d'un très
mauvais oeil ce qui se passe en tunisie
et ce sont les plus actifs les plus
restrictifs les européens c'est un peu
différent les européens ils sont gênés
aux entournures d'abord parce que il ya
une bienveillance naturel est depuis
longtemps vis-à-vis de la tunisie
ensuite parce que la tunisie ne
fonctionne encore que grâce au soutien
des européens ceux qui sont contre
l'ingérence étrangère ils payent leur
dette ils dépendent pas de l'étranger
quand la tunisie a été colonisé c'est en
1880 c'était à cause du surendetté
situent déjà ça c'était à cause du
surendettement donc aujourd'hui elle est
surendetté parce qu'elle est très mal
géré donc ceux qui gèrent la tunisie
devrait mieux l'ajac les européens ils
sont gênés parce que d'abord ils veulent
pas de déstabilisation lorsque leur
sujet premier c'est la stabilité et
notamment les français les français ils
préfèrent être un peu en arrière mains
parce qu'on ne les entendent pas on les
entend pas parce que quoi qu'ils disent
ils seront attaqués dans un sens ou dans
un autre s'ils soutiennent trop ils vont
être attaquées par les opposants s'il
critique ils vont être attaquées par le
président il ya tellement de liens
politiques économiques et humains qu'ils
préfèrent rester
resté discret mais et donc les européens
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils ont donné très
récemment 380 millions d'euros pour
payer à peu près les salaires des
fonctionnaires donc il essaye d'assurer
la stabilité ils veulent voir jusqu'où
ça va aller le processus de transition
politique mais si la constitution est
présenté aux tunisiens dix jours avant
l'élection si cette constitution est une
constitution totalement présidentialiste
et si le jour du référendum le résultat
est grotesque parce qu'il y aura eu très
peu de participation les européens ils
vont se retourner ils vont dire
maintenant c'est fini mais ceux qui
seront à la manoeuvre le plus en avant
ce seront les américains justement alors
vous pouvez rebondir là dessus la
tunisie s'isole alors je voudrais
rebondir sur le plus des d'américaines
la dérive autoritaire et sur ce qu'il
donnait en tout cas depuis le 25 juillet
nous n'avons pas d'assassinât politique
nous n'avons pas vous les opposants
manifestent librement alors dites moi où
est ce qu'il ya une dictature où les
opposants à la dictature manifeste
librement qui que monsieur sayed en tant
que président dans son processus de 25
mille juifs à 100 de
moi je me souviens quand je tourne
politique en 2013 jarjat ce crible les
idées et mon âme au diable abc
d'assassinats politiques et j'en passe
et des meilleurs et moi je me souviens
d'elle je me souviens d'un plateau de
jalboun ballack où il disait que hay
nahda c'est le terrorisme est
aujourd'hui de le voir moi dans le même
camp et manifesté côte à côte et faire
des réunions avec el ghanouchi et toute
la clique d'annaba je trouve ça pour le
moins arriviste surtout messi en
isolement international sur les eaux
internationales la tueuse dit elle se
met en danger
certes nous avons des preuves nous nous
avons un problème à régler là dessus
maintenant nous avons un processus nous
avons un calendrier la communauté
internationale a demandé à quel seuil
est de donner de la visibilité donner un
calendrier il l'a fait donc aujourd'hui
les conditions aujourd'hui ne sont pas
très tranchées donc bien évidemment ils
attendent le respect de ce calendrier il
est certain que c'est un dérapage sur ce
calendrier les discussions vont être
différentes maintenant nous tenons à
notre souveraineté nationale je pense
que le calendrier aujourd'hui qui est
posée
c'est du nationalisme nous vous ai
formés
en france quand on parle de souveraineté
on parle de souveraineté à gauche en
parle de souveraineté à droite c'est pas
forcément du nationaliste jean pierre
chevènement parle de souveraineté c'est
pas des notions
ne souhaite pas nous couper de personnes
par contre nous souhaitons redistribuer
de son hôte en retire nos relations
internationales sur des bases de gagnant
gagnant et sur des et sur des et sur des
des relations d'égal à égal aujourd'hui
les relations que la tunisie bien
évidemment ils sont a dit drissi le
saurais si lou hakim el karoui la
souveraineté c'est payer ses dettes la
souveraineté ce n'est ce n'est pas
délaissée ne pas dépendre des autres
pays pour pouvoir payer ses
fonctionnaires la souveraineté
aujourd'hui c'est faire des réformes la
souveraineté c'est ouvrir le pays qui a
eu qui a eu un écho un élan de sympathie
internationale extraordinaire après les
printemps arabes seule démocratie du
proche orient du monde arabe qui en
train aujourd'hui de se refermer si je
le contraire c'est le contraire la
souveraineté le pays va dans le mur un
pays qui va dans le mur ce n'est pas un
pays souverain la société c'est aussi de
relier aussi les contrats qui sont
déséquilibrés que nous avons avec
l'occident avec la france qu'elle
compterait pas par exemple de la dette à
0 2% pendant 20 ans
et nous voulons pas des nouveaux n'ont
pas de charité et nous prions nos dettes
et si on fout on fait des réformes qui
s'imposent et ce notamment d'un grand
maghreb notamment une réforme agraire
importante sa fille wanda la fonction
publique bien évidemment que nous serons
en mesure de payer nos dettes et là on
pourra parler différemment par contre
aujourd'hui quand je vois des relations
déséquilibrées et ben là je dis il ya
problème de souveraineté nationale et de
mauvaise gestion est très grave il faut
sortir de cet isolement dans lequel la
tunisie s'est mise et je parle de la
tunisie puisque on parle de relations
d'état à état et il faut prendre
conscience que
on n'a que cette question de référendum
ne doit pas masquer l'essentiel qui est
essentiel c'est les réformes économiques
immédiates c'est pas demain matin c'est
ce soir deuxièmement on n'est pas
manifestement n'y est pas et c'est ça la
conscience deuxième jaune et il y a un
problème il faut rendre compte de ça
parce qu'on aimerait n'ont pas été
menées depuis ces deux prisons depuis
depuis depuis depuis plusieurs plus que
dix ans le problème est le suivant il
faut pas masquer le problème de la
réforme de la justice parce que in
économie ne peut par exemple mais sans
une justice et aujourd'hui personne n'a
voulu cantonner dans l'opposition on
appelle à l'indépendance de gist quand
on prend le pouvoir on oublie ça c'est
cette ce problème en un problème réel
avec cette histoire là et donc pour que
l'écho pour que la tunisie
reviennent dans l'ess sur la scène
alternative ne fait pas confiance à
cassayet pour faire ces réformes mais
12h30 à la classe politique dans dans
une grande partie il faut que les gens
prennent conscience si cassette demain
décide de renouer avec l'union
européenne avec la communauté
internationale
et pourquoi pas si les autres qui ont
gouverné avant qu'ils nous disent qu'ils
ont fait des erreurs et qui est qui et
qui équiperont et qui reviennent dans
dans le dans les standards
internationaux très bien le problème
n'est pas personnel le problème
puisqu'il s'enfoncer psion qui est
complètement erronée alors parlons de
réformes politiques économiques et bien
évidemment des réformes économiques à
son urgente aujourd'hui mail c'est
urgent de 4,3 en un sergent qui a 5 ans
et serge enfin voilà il est il est au
peuple et la demande bien évidemment de
russie s'apprête à lui et à boire
économique alors peut-être qu'il faut
aller plus vite mais il fallait aussi
aller plus vite avant ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'ils les rides et
compliqué il est au pouvoir bien
évidemment il ya des priorités nous
pensons nous que la priorité aujourd'hui
est les institutionnels et les
politiques ça n'empêche que les réformes
économiques sont très importantes et
résurgente il faut les faire il faut les
faire dans le temps qu'il faut qu'il
faut il faut forer les faut aller vite
mais le plus important aujourd'hui c'est
de mettre en place une nouvelle
constituera un nouveau système politique
un nouveau système électoral voire bin
mubarak pour reprendre le titre de cette
émission quel est l'avenir de la tunisie
de kaïs aide
d'abord un petit mot sur la question de
nasa oui oui le vrai opportunisme et
l'arrivisme c'est de soutenir un pouvoir
populiste c'est ça le véritable il
implique l'arrivée
2 et de deux moi j'étais content nasa
quand elle était au pouvoir
et maintenant je suis contre le pouvoir
toujours nous débrouiller de quel côté
je suis et puis et puis je rappelle
simplement que nous n'avons pas eu
d'assassinât politique depuis 2012 avant
alors arrêtons de de surfer ici c'est
2013 ou début 2014
et puis et puis sur la juste quelques
mots sur la question sur la question
économique d'abord
il évoquera besoins seraient démocratie
parce que j'aurai conclut justement
cette question de démocratie puisque
c'était le modèle c'est ce modèle
original de la tunisie pendant les
révolutions arabes oui je pense que je
pense simplement que ce que rezaï dès
qu'une parenthèse est une parenthèse
dans la transition démocratique c'est
s'étale obstacles à la transition
démocratique c'est un obstacle passagers
que la lutte va continuer que son
programme va échouer parce que je pense
que les tunisiens profondément sont
attachés à aux valeurs démocratiques aux
valeurs républicaines et à l'état de
droit alors je pense qu'en fin de compte
et ça n a pas de perspective sans projet
il n'a pas de perspective et ça se voit
les indices de cette déchéance elles et
ils sont là il ya un plein dans glee sur
la question de sa popularité cela sur
l'adhésion des partis politiques et des
forces politiques et des forces de la
société civile au projet de paix side il
est maintenant isolé isolé à l'intérieur
isolé internationalement et son projet
se heurte à un refus général de
en tunisie et à l'international au
sikkim état où je pense qu'il y aura
bientôt chang e tour semaine retour à la
démocratie mais un retour aussi aux
réformes parce que c'est ce qu'attendent
les tunisiens c'est de véritables
réformes justes de scénarii un scénario
de très grande instabilité parce que
sinon on n'a pas parlé c'est les
conditions de vie des tunisiens c'est le
blé dur le blé tendre c'est à dire le
couscous le baie le pain et les pâtres
qui vont devenir inabordable et donc ça
ça va ça sacré les révolte du pain les
émeutes du pain les tunisiens s'en
souviennent donc il ya ce scénario-là
très très très dangereux et maintenant
il ya un autre scénario c'est la
tentation autoritaire ou plus
qu'autoritaire la dictature soit certes
highside qui va au bout de son processus
soit c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui vient
et qui dit écoutez merci monsieur à
bientôt et qui prend la place et ça
c'est un très grand risque et donc je
crois vraiment qu'il faut revenir
réouvrir le dialogue réouvrir le
dialogue avec les partenaires
internationaux qui financent la tunisie
et la tunisie devrait les en remercier
ré ouvrir le dialogue avec les tunisiens
pour maintenant apaiser les tensions et
très très vite relancer la machine
économique qui est complètement à la rue
merci beaucoup acquis match écart ou
d'avoir été avec no mercy avoue abdel
majid azimi merci d'avoir été avec non
duplex de tunis jaguar bin mubarak et
merci à vous magie de boudenne merci à
vous tous nous avoir suivis rester avec
nous sur france 24 vous pourrez
retrouver le débat sur notre podcast
[Musique]